the forza horizon series has already
crossed over with numerous franchises
from the building blocks of lego to the
family in fast and the furious but it's
the one with hot wheels and forza
horizon 3 that sticks out the most when
looking back the combination of
horizon's blisteringly fast cars and the
creativity of hot wheels twisty tracks
was an unsurprising hit making its
return in forza horizon 5 an anticipate
one
it's an expansion that manages to
deliver the same thrill as before with
new track types and a much larger map
but also a structure to progression
hampers the pacing the orange highways
of this new expansion are strewn across
the sky over mexico creating a racing
paradise nestled in the clouds just
waiting to be torn through the map is
larger than the one previously offered
in forza horizon 3 featuring three
biomes that introduce different weather
conditions depending on where you are
they're also a big reason why this new
playground is immediately engrossing the
introduction into the map has you
speeding through each part of it while
taking in the best sights from dropping
down almost vertically into an active
volcano inside a snowy mountain to
sliding down water laden shoots in a
thick jungle the recognizable hot wheels
track pieces that let you navigate these
areas are beautifully contrasted against
the natural beauty around them making
the entire space feel like a daydream
come to life the plastic pieces of the
raceway are also more varied this time
around which does accentuate the playful
nature of the entire expansion magnetic
strips suck you down onto the track
letting you complete parts of a race
upside down or creating intricate loops
where maintaining speed is paramount
others are laden with thick layers of
ice making navigating even some of the
wildest corners a satisfying challenge
as you struggle to maintain grip the
most exhilarating are stretches of road
with giant overhead fans each of which
boosts your speed to new heights not
possible to reach in the main portion of
forza horizon 5. it's a thrill to be
flung around corners at these ridiculous
speeds feeling like you're barely
hanging on when braving them with some
of the fastest cars in the game
your progression through this new map is
dictated by a stricter format than you
might expect from the horizon series
which usually lets you achieve anything
you want in any direction here you're
initially limited to b-class cars and
must work your way towards increasing
your rank to access faster ones you
increase your rank by collecting medals
which are awarded for participating in
races sprints and smaller contextual
events such as speed traps drift zones
and popping floating balloons around the
map several missions also lump many of
these activities together rewarding you
with more medals for completing a
collection of races or completing small
challenges around the map with your
current class of cars the structure
makes sense in the context of slowly
introducing you to faster and faster
cars as you come to grips with the new
challenges that this expansion has to
offer but it does alter the pace to one
that feels more like you're checking
things off a list rather than
progressing through doing the types of
activities you enjoy this is especially
true when considering how few events
there are at each new driving rank that
you unlock with you needing to do almost
everything in order to progress and
unlock new events i love doing races and
cinematic showcase events but i wasn't
as thrilled with the downtime i was
forced to take when hunting down speed
traps in order to unlock more of what i
wanted tossed in with the standard
racing events is a new five-part story
driven series that acts as a deep dive
into the hot wheels franchise while
taking some of its most iconic vehicles
10 of which are included in the
expansion out for a spin this series
mimics the structure of the one centered
around the volkswagen beetle in the main
campaign of forza horizon 5 starting at
the origin of hot wheels and charting
its meteoric rise over the years as the
series went from a simple children's toy
to prize collectible car series while
the information is certainly interesting
if you're unfamiliar with it the
delivery comes off as less sincere and
more advertorial in quite a few spots it
was easier to view the vwb or through
the lens of its history in mexican car
culture than it is to listen to a ramble
of factoids delivered by a character who
proudly exclaims to have memorized it or
by the age of six
which makes the entire series quite
uneven thankfully most of the joy you're
likely to squeeze out of this return to
hot wheels is in the high octane racing
taking place in the skies and it's
during these moments where it's a bit
easier to forget about its unfortunate
shortcomings the expanded map and the
diverse geographic makeup is a joy to
explore as is coming to grips with all
the new pieces of plastic track services
that keep otherwise routine races from
turning stale it's disappointing that
this energy couldn't be entirely
converted over to the expansion's love
letter to the hot wheels franchise and
it's annoying to be routinely reminded
of all the other types of events you
need to complete in order to unlock some
of the best new vehicles but it's still
a detour worth taking if you've been
itching for another effects of forza
horizon fun